للمتابعه ينضم الينا من مراسله الجزيره
عامر لافي مرحبا عامر من جديد اذا بدات
تتضح اكثر صوره ذلك الهجوم الذي وصف
بالمباغت والذي قامت به القوات الجويه
الروسيه وصدفت مشارف العاصمه الاوكرانيه
نعم محمد هو الهدف كان مركز العاصمه كيف
لكن اسقاط هذه الصواريخ
شظايا هذه الصواريخ سقطت على اطراف
العاصمه وتحديدا هنا في هذه البلده التي
تبعد تقريبا نحو 50 كيلومتر جنوب العاصمه
كييف هذه البلده الان الان سمح او سيسمح
بالدخول والاقتراب نحن كنت ساقول قبل قليل
بان الشرطه من عدنا من الاقتراب الى ان
تنتهي التحقيقات وفحص ما اذا كان هناك
مواد متفجره لكن الان ترفع الاشرطه التي
كانت تمنعنا من الدخول بعد قليل سنتمكن من
الاقتراب اكثر من هذا المكان اعود لشرح
الوضع كما ذكرت هذه القريه التي تبعد
تقريبا 50 كلم الى الجنوب سقطت شظايا على
عشره منازل في هذه
المبنى الذي ترونه امامكم واكثر المباني
تضررا للمباينه والمفارقه ان هذا المبنى
كان يعيش فيه شخصان كبيران في السن رجل
المراه لم يتضرران لانهما كان ينامان في
الطابق السفلي في الجهه الاخرى للمكان
الذي سقطت فيه الشظايا وبالتالي لم يحدث
شيء لهما لكن الشخصان الذين اصيباهم كان
في المنزل القريب من هذا المنزل يقول اهل
القريه بان معجزه حصلت حتى لا يصاب هذان
الشخصان باذى كما تلاحظون دمار كبير حدث
خوف ورعب عاشته هذه القريه في حوالي
الساعه الرابعه بين الرابعه والخامسه من
فجر هذا اليوم بعد سقوط هذه الشظايا طبعا
كما ذكرنا عشره منازل ايضا مخزن لتخزين
الادوات الزراعيه على اعتبار هذه المنطقه
منطقه زراعيه قريه خارج مدينه كييف ايضا
العديد من السيارات القريه تضررت وفقا
لقياده القوات الجويه ما جره وان قوات
الدفاع الجوي تمكنت من اسقاط اربعه صواريخ
كانت تستهدف العاصمه كييف هذه الصواريخ
اطلقت من قاذفات من نوع تيو 95
كانت تحلق فوق بحر قزوين واستهدفت العاصمه
كان هناك محمد انذار على كل تقريبا معظم
المقاطعات الاوكرانيه لان الصواريخ
المستخدمه هي صواريخ من نوع كروز عده
انواع من نوع كروز 55
و55
وهذه صواريخ جواله تقول القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه بان هذه الصواريخ بدات
بالتجوال وتغيير مسارها ولم يتحدد هدفها
الا في اللحظات الاخيره وبالتالي كان هناك
انذار في معظم المقاطعات التركي المقاطعات
الاوكرانيه عفوا بما فيها التي تقع في
اقصى غرب اوكرانيا لكن قوات الدفاع الجوي
تمكنت من اسقاط هذه
الصواريخ الاربعه كما ذكرنا هي من نوع
كروز واضح طبعا انه وبالاعتناء باعتماد
على ما صرحت به المتحدثه باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب ان ما جرى هو محاوله لتمويه
ومناوره لله الدفاعات الارضيه الاوكرانيه
بما جرى من عمليه تغيير المسارات ايضا
هناك ما قامت به القوات الروسيه من تغيير
حامله الصواريخ التي كانت تتمركز في بحر
ازوف وارسالها الى البحر الاسود في محاوله
للايحاء بان عمليه القصف ستكون كالمعتاد
من البحر الاسود لكن القصف تم من خلال هذه
القاذفات تيو 95 كما ذكرنا لكن الى الان
وتحذيرا من قياده عمليات الجنوب تقول بان
الان هناك في البحر الاسود حامله صواريخ
تحمل ثمانيه من صواريخ كروز وهي متاهبه
للاطلاق ولذلك دعوا الجميع للحذر وانتظار
احتمال ان تكون اوديسا او كييف في مرمى
هذه الصواريخ شكرا جزيلا عامر لا في مراسل
للجزيره كنت معنا من كي